Hello, I'm Jamal Johnson.
You may know me from athletic podcasting
but you might not know I'm
also a renowned art critic.
And I am here on Los Feliz,
one of Los Angeles whitest neighborhoods
to critique Black Lives Matter art.
I didn't go to any official
schools or art programs
but I did attend the school of hard knock.
Let's go see how long it
takes for me to get arrested.
(calm music)
Whenever I see high quality
printouts like this,
I say to myself,
thank goodness a white person
has felt strongly enough
about my people being shot by the police
to email a high res
photo to FedEx Kinko's.
This next one has a
bit of an outsider art,
Daniel Johnston Esq. kind of field,
by which I mean it's bad, it's pretty bad.
It's very, very thin, very
uniform lines, very Tim Burton.
Of course this building
doesn't have any signs at all
but these little babies
are kinda hard though.
The handcrafted nature of this sign
lets me know that these white people
are actually broke as fuck.
And maybe they didn't do
that well in high school.
This is a truly thin to fine print.
You have to look very close.
You have to pull out a Monaco
to see if these people really
think black lives matter.
Also they definitely took this sign
from their restaurant job.
This may just actually be a brunch menu.
Yeah, like this is just some gang shit
but it's good to know the
neighborhood still has a pulse.
Oh my God, guys come here.
Follow me.
Look at this.
This is what I'm talking about.
This is what we're looking for.
Real art.
Apparently these white homeowners,
who benefited from systemic racism,
want to dismantle it now.
I can't believe what I'm seeing.
They also added the popular slogan, ACAB,
which stands for All Cops Are Bastards,
which is impressive
because their uncle is
the chief of police.
And so what have we learned today?
Not much, to be honest.
Do black lives matter?
Absolutely.
Aside from that, art is what you make it.
When you decide to show
your support for black lives
just know that I don't care
about you in the slightest.
Art!